[Music]
hi guys I'm still in Maui which is why I
haven't been posting as many videos here
as I normally would but I hope you guys
enjoyed the Shane Dawson cameo YouTube
hater video had a lot of fun making that
anyway while I'm here I wanted to share
with you guys a few video clips that
I've taken
I bought this underwater housing for my
Canon camera so I have been going
snorkeling I've been filming and taking
so many photos of well pretty much
everything underwater
[Music]
this guy was feeding a sea turtle which
actually I don't think you're allowed to
turn but he was doing in his native
seaweed we're so funny because while
he's feeding it we could pull onto the
bag of seaweed we had to put sweeties
Jones
[Music]
my favorite clips though because I put
the camera with the case in the sand and
then I fed some birds ships in the
attack
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
oh and as a lot of you guys know I'm
deathly afraid of water slides I got rid
of my fear and I went down a waterslide
all by myself put my camera so I get
suppose really dry myself this you guys
[Music]
alright well thanks for watching leave
me a comment with which clip is your
favorite and I'll see you guys on the
Internet
[Music]